Hi, I'm Fred Shapiro.
I'm the associate director of
the Law Library here at Yale.
I'm also the editor of The New
Yale Book of Quotations,
and I'm here to talk about
that book and talk about
a few of the quotations that
I particularly like or that are
particularly meaningful
and why I selected them.
Black Lives Matter,
obviously, is a very big quote
in our political
and social life,
and it was first
coined by a writer and activist
named Alicia Garza.
We're living in a very
turbulent, crazy time,
which has generated
many remarkable quotes
and Black Lives Matter. It's
a very short quote.
It's really a slogan,
but it's had such a
tremendous influence
on our culture and
our politics in recent years
that I think its merits
speak for themselves.
"Believe those who are seeking
the truth, doubt
those who find it." by
the French writer André Gide.
This encapsulates
the one of the big issues
of our time, which is
truth and accuracy
versus fabrications.
It addresses the phenomenon
which is so prevalent
now of people that are
fanatics or are narrowly
focused on a particular
agenda. "Nobody loves
me but my mother,
and she could be jivin' too."
by the musician B.B. King.
There is a lot of humor in the
book, a lot of wit and humor.
I particularly like this quote,
I'd like to include
quotes from the arts,
from the music world.
And this one, I just thought
was a particularly funny one.
"I am not smart, but genius
and a very stable genius
at that!" Donald J. Trump.
This quote is amazing
on many levels. This is someone
who many people feel
is not smart and
not a genius and not stable.
But yet he prides himself
on those those very attributes.
This is not a book
that only has admirable,
eloquent quotations.
It has quotations
that are famous.
That's one of the big criteria
for inclusion, quotations
that are historically
important. And Mr.
Trump has many of those.
"There is nothing to be
learned from history anymore.
We're in science fiction now."
by Allen Ginsberg.
I know I personally
have the sense, but maybe many
others have the sense that
we've crossed some kind
of divide, that instead of
watching postapocalyptic
movies, maybe we're living
in a post apocalyptic movie,
and that's what Ginsberg
was meaning to convey
even a few decades ago
when he said that quote.
"I don't want to
belong to any club
that would accept me as one of
its members." by Groucho Marx,
and this is a quote
that has a lot of psychological
validity that many people feel.
"God grant me the serenity
to accept the things
I cannot change,
courage to change the things
I can, and the wisdom
to know the difference." This
is the famous Serenity Prayer,
and it has a very complex
and rich origin story.
It's usually attributed
to Reinhold Niebuhr,
who was a great theologian and
a great political philosopher.
I've done a lot of
research on this prayer,
and almost 20 years
have been studying this.
Niebuhr's daughter
says that in 1943 was when her
father sat down and wrote it.
But if you search newspaper
indexes, newspaper databases,
you'll find that it was used
as far back as 1933.
The earliest record
we have of someone using it was
a woman named Winifred Weigel.
An official of the YWCA wrote
The Serenity Prayer,
we believe, and she's
the earliest known user of it.
And she is a completely obscure
woman. Reinhold Niebuhr
is a very, very famous man.
And this is actually
a pattern that I found
in preparing my book, that
there were many famous quotes
by obscure women
that are attributed
to famous men, prominent men.
And this, I think, is the most
interesting example of that,
and in my book I go into some
detail in explaining the story,
the true story of the Serenity
Prayer and its origins.